there's an odd thing about love novels
that doesn't tend to get talked about
much most of them are about how
relationships start they spend their
time tracking how a couple gets together
the excitement is all around the issues
of will they or won't they
and then when finally they do get
together there's often not much else for
the novelist to do except assure us in
so many words that they'll live happily
ever after or else the characters get
killed off in some gruesome way you know
the kind of thing her body is found
floating in the canal he's hacked up and
put in the icebox
what's far harder to find however is a
love novel that's about how most of our
love lives actually go which is neither
quite happily ever after' nor disaster
death prison and outright heart-rending
calamity but something in the middle we
need such novels because novels are like
road maps we use to make sense of things
that happen to us so imagine a novel
that looked not so much at the start of
love but how love developed matured and
grew over time a novel that wasn't
gruesome or catastrophic but was deeply
sometimes hilariously honest about how
actual relationships really are a novel
that gave us a sense we weren't alone
with the complexities of love a novel in
which you'd constantly recognize your
own experiences expressed beautifully
and crisply a novel whether characters
were sympathetic but didn't seem
unrealistic or sentimental a novel that
wanted to be fun and gripping but also
eye-opening and mind-expanding a hopeful
generous novel that showed you that love
was ultimately a skill not an enthusiasm
and one we can all learn and get better
at through understanding that's what a
land a baton the guy behind the channel
you'll know his voice has produced a
deeply original and entertaining novel
called the course of love those of you
who've enjoyed his mind here will love
what you read the book is published
around the world you can order it here
the US and here in the UK
you